welcome back uh the last talk for today
is going to be benign tempered or
catastrophic taxonomy of overfitting uh
we're going to have Neil malinar
speaking who's a PhD student at UC San
Diego and I believe pritam will be
joining uh to speak in the second half
of the talk just take away
hello uh thank you very much for joining
me today at 4pm I appreciate your time
I'm going to be talking to you today
about some work called benign tempered
catastrophic the taxonomy of overfitting
this paper is in review currently
um this work has been ongoing for the
last year in largely Misha's lab with
some help from a student here at UC
Berkeley a co-first author of mine and
uh we are very inspired by a lot of the
theory and empirical works that many of
the people in this room have presented
and we've come up with some interesting
experiments and theoretical ideas that
we want to share with you if you came in
December to the Simon's Workshop preetam
presented an early version of some of
those experiments which sort of
motivated some of the other theoretical
angles that we get into and I'm looking
forward to talking to you about it
uh I should put an asterisk here that uh
we do call it a taxonomy of overfitting
but we'll consider some underfit methods
as well uh it's primarily a taxonomy of
overfitting because interpolating
methods sort of led us to uh these
results and they're perhaps more
interesting but uh to really round out
the fact that we have a taxonomy uh we
will consider some underfit methods and
we'll show how they fall under the
taxonomy as well uh so
without further Ado uh these are
uh the people who contributed to this
work so Jamie uh unfortunately couldn't
be here but I think he'll be around for
the rest of the week as a student at UC
Berkeley a PhD student in the Deweese
lab Amir Assam is a student in nisha's
lab who's here uh part of the postdoc
you all know Misha and pritam who's now
at Apple uh uh contributed heavily to
this work
so we'll start with the classic story of
overfitting this is something that you
should all be very familiar with if you
type overfitting into Google you will
find these images and it should be no
surprise a lot of the conventional
wisdom for overfitting says these sort
of jagged and Wiggly lines are not good
so these images are often characterized
by some reasonably clean decision
boundary that you want to do regression
on or classification and these sort of
Wiggly lines that contort themselves to
fit noise in your training data and
we're told that this is very undesirable
at least classically
so on the left I've given an extreme
example of what this really undesirable
type behavior is with these types of
contorted polynomials but on the other
hand modern thinking says to just
interpolate and you can generalize
fairly well and maybe these kind of
Wiggly and jagged lines aren't so bad
and you might end up with a function
like what you see here on the right
where
you have some train set with noise
there's a true function that you want to
learn and your predictor actually models
it fairly well while sort of having
these spikes to fit the label noise
and uh
it leads us to the question of how
harmful
is overfitting for standard deep neural
networks
and this is sort of what motivated us to
begin this study
before continuing I'm going to give a
little bit of notation which I'll use to
define certain things in the next few
slides and then when we get into the
kernel regression setting we'll give
more notation as needed
we have some estimator trained on and
samples from an underlying distribution
X cross R and we denoted by F hat sub n
there's the population risk for mean
squared error something you're all
familiar with we'll use R star to denote
the optimal risk where we take them in
over all measurable functions here the
Bayes risk and then R sub n is the
expected risk of an estimator trained on
N samples
and the question which uh naughty set up
very well and a lot of the people that
you've been hearing is what is the limit
as you add more samples this is a
question of consistency so uh what is
the limit as n goes to Infinity of R sub
n
foreign
to these two examples that I presented
earlier of the sort of classical
thinking about overfitting and this
modern thinking of overfitting
and I'm gonna call
the classical setting catastrophic so
this limit goes off to infinity and this
is a very very undesirable Behavior
and we'll call this
benign where the limit approaches R star
the optimal
and you'll notice there's some Gap in
the middle and
we've all probably observed a number of
functions that lie in this middle regime
and we're going to put a name to it and
we're going to call it tempered
overfitting
so
the limit converges to something that is
neither catastrophic
nor benign so there is some
harm incurred by overfitting but
perhaps it's not
so bad
I'll note in the case of a classifier
which we will study first experimentally
uh these Infinities would be replaced by
the risk of a random classifier where
you'll use the zero one loss and so uh
instead of infinity here you'll have a k
minus 1 over k for a k-class problem
so I'll return to the question of how
harmful is overfitting for standard deep
neural networks
and I'll start with a simple experiment
something you've all seen now a few
times and yesterday in today's
presentations
uh we train
a wide resnet it's a version of a
residual convolutional Network on a
binary version of c410 so we take uh
four of the animal classes for the
object classes and on the left here we
don't add any label noise and we plot
the classification error on a clean test
set over the number of training samples
and we see that as you add more training
samples your test error improves
and on the right we flip 30 of the
labels and you've seen this experiment
before uh Spencer presented it uh Nadi
had a similar slide where as you had
more training samples
you basically have this 30
classification error when you flipped 30
of the training labels
so this is not all together surprising
and one thing to note here is that
perhaps in the pursuit of a benign
method uh you would want even in this
case when you're just doing binary
classification as you add more data you
would want some improvement if you're
very resilient to the noise
and that will sort of motivate some of
the later ideas that we're going to get
into
I'm going to extend this experiment in
the following way
I'm going to put
the label noise on the x-axis
so on the classification label noise is
the probability of flipping a label to a
different class
and I'm going to keep the classification
error on the y-axis
where we're measuring against the clean
test set where we haven't perturbed
labels on the test set
and a few things to note uh on this plot
a catastrophic method is a random
classifier so with any amount of label
noise uh you're just outputting random
labels this is very bad
we'll say a benign method lies along
this bottom line here until you flip 50
of the labels so
as you add more label noise if you're
really not harmed
you will essentially get
an optimal classifier until you flip
half of the labels in which case the
best you can do is random
and now I'm going to plot uh lines for
different values of n so where before I
change the n on the x-axis
I'll put n
uh different lines for different values
of N and what we see for these resonance
that are interpolating is that the error
is actually
changing as a function of label noise
this is something we've observed before
and as you add more samples
while at very low label noise there's
some improvement
you're sort of nearly always lying along
this kind of line especially if you look
here at 30 error up to 50 more data is
not
really improving the test performance
for these neural networks that are
interpolating the training set
[Music]
yeah this is the clean 10 set on
perturbed slaves my favorite
so the zero one loss on the the test set
with uh with the normal labels no lips
oh okay so it is the excess this is the
excess yes yes it is
they are they're interpolating in the
training classification
so all of these models have 100 training
so we're working with 32 by 32 images
and three channels so great about 32 by
32.
um
orbit you flipped it yeah
in this case it's finer so yeah one and
you just flip to the other class
it's zero uh yeah well so uh
even with zero label noise you can see
that we have some non-trivial error here
but it's likely that we just don't have
access to enough points and uh what
we're arguing is that in the case of a
simple binary classification experiment
if you're not harmed by label noise for
binary classification even with uh up to
50 label noise you should a consistent
method should learn something that lies
closer to this line right here
um zero is essentially like
experimentally I I don't know that we'll
get that with this finite sample
that is
the information
well yeah in this experimental setup
we'll say that uh overfitting is not
exactly benign when we call benign truly
harmless interpolation but tempered
is not so bad and tempered may be more
practically
mirrors what we see in certain setups
like this where you can keep adding
training data and you want to train your
models and see how they improve
we often see that training data sets are
extended over time and measuring tests
accuracy on them
you find that some classical methods
that essentially the
Texas risk converge to zero yeah well
I'm glad you asked because we'll
actually show exactly those experiments
uh very shortly and you will see what a
more benign method would look like in
the case where it's not interpolating
and that maybe alludes to some sort of
tension between the tribulation and true
uh not being harmed by label noise so
for the blue line that says
so do you show videos
approach
es yeah it will theoretically show uh
that's the case and we'll also
theoretically recover the benign
overfitting conditions that you are
familiar with when you don't have a
ridge and that will be interpolating but
experimentally kind of as Gil was
mentioning we will show that when you
don't interpolate you can actually get
very close to this benign line here but
theoretically we will show that this is
the case
so an outline for where we're going to
go I'm going to give some examples in
the taxonomy and generally how you might
use this and put methods into different
categories
I'll talk a little bit about some
empirical results that was shown using
deep Journal networks which have
motivated a lot of this work and then
finally preview is going to look at
overfitting in the case of chronal
regression specifically
so uh some prior works I I know that I
have omitted a lot but we've sort of
been inspired by a lot of works and I
can't include every citation but uh
We've we've really uh want to point out
that
when you take D being the input
Dimension and ending the number of
samples many of these Works will find
that benign overfitting is shown when D
is larger than n or when n and D scale
jointly and otherwise you'll get some
work showing generalization error bounds
in d and n and our work is cohesive with
all of this and I also want to point out
uh G Leon talgarsky shows some early
stopped consistency of neural networks
and we'll look at some experiments in
this realm
as well
so really the motivation for a taxonomy
comes from the fact that we're
considering a problem where we're fixing
the input Dimension D and we're taking
the number of samples off to Infinity
and in this setting what we're calling
benign is consistent consistency
and something we hadn't noticed is prior
works we'll say things like uh when you
have a lower fixed dimension
certain kernel interpolators are
inconsistent uh Rockland and I showed
that for the laplacian kernel a recently
beagle hole Belkin and pundit show that
for some classes of shift invariant
kernels including the gaussian kernel
and they'll say that in low Dimension or
fixed Dimension kernel interpolators are
inconsistent
and what we want to say as well is that
there are two ways to be inconsistent
when interpolating
that is tempered where you have a
bounded risk as you add more samples and
what we'll show in the kernel regression
setting is that this is a function of
the label noise
and there's catastrophic where you have
an unbounded Roost and we want to
motivate that perhaps being inconsistent
in a tempered way is not so bad and
that's in line with some of the
observations of deep neural networks
saying fitting the noise is not so bad
we find that they are tempered but we'll
show that there is something there are
methods that are catastrophic
[Music]
in these experiments we are fixing the
architecture to be sufficiently large to
interpolate as we increase the number of
samples but uh we do allow for changing
architecture and I think it would be
interesting to look at what are maybe
some principled ways that you might
change the architecture as a function of
n in order to maintain but for the
experiments we're showing neural
networks we fix the architecture
so uh we'll point out some example
methods in this taxonomy on the left
here we have benign or consistent and
I'll just comment that in the ridge
kernel which we'll show later and K N
you're not interpolating so I'll just
call this benign fitting you will have a
consistent method and it does approach
the Bayes risk as you add more samples
and then you have the notary Watson
estimator with a singular kernel which
is an interpolating method that in our
setting is benign
uh and tempered where your risk is
bounded between optimal and infinitely
bad uh we'll show experiments that
interpolating dnns under this
experimental setup that we've presented
are tempered we'll also see that the
laplacian kernel regression without a
ridge is tempered
and of course the Canon with a constant
K is tempered this is something that we
know
and then uh catastrophic you have models
of the double descent Peak a polynomial
regression with a degree equal to the
number of samples and what we'll
actually show is that the gaussian
kernel Ridge a kernel regression without
a ridge is catastrophic so delineating
between tempered and catastrophic allows
us to create two settings in which we
have these results saying laplacian and
gaussian kernel are inconsistent what we
actually see which matches some
experimental results of papers by Misha
if you've seen the laplacian kernel is
tempered which is perhaps not so bad
while the gaussian kernel and the
original setting is catastrophic
is there any examples of interpolating
methods
[Music]
yeah I could uh just memorize my
training data and predict randomly on
anything else
yeah
also polynomial regression right
you have examples of any methods that
don't fall it's indeterminate which
category of
yeah so uh
there is a consideration that the limit
doesn't exist
as far as I know there's no kind of
non-pathological examples like if you're
using a learning method we all use I
think this limit should exist
maybe you can construct some settings in
which you're constantly oscillating
between I don't know getting better and
getting worse as you add more samples
I'm not actually sure it would be
interesting I don't know if anybody has
any ideas about that but it would
certainly be interesting to think about
if the limit doesn't exist what does
that mean
so uh I'm gonna further give a sort of
visual intuition for how example methods
might fall into the taxonomy through an
experiment where we're classifying a
binary version of mnist so we're looking
at even and odd digits and I'm going to
plot the same plot that I showed you
earlier
for a variety of methods and we'll see
at a glance how just looking at how the
method sort of reacts to label noise
sort of tells us whether you're falling
into this benign category or not
uh so here we'll see k n with some
scaling of K as about log n
and what I'm plotting here is
a thousand samples 10 000 samples and
sixty thousand samples and each of these
lines is averaged over five independent
runs and you can see even up to
some modest amount of label noise that
the test air is doing fairly well and
it's it's bending towards that right
corner which is what we would desire of
benignness
uh in the spirit of the early stopping
results being consistent we we also look
at a one Epoch MLP trained on the same
problem and we actually see that even up
to 40 label noise we're having less than
10 test error on the clean test Set uh
we'll look at a bit more of a
complicated example of early stopping
because feminist is remarkably easy so
maybe this won't convince you but we'll
show you another example
and then on the other hand uh onen as
you would classically expect as you add
more samples approaches Y equals X
and overfit MLP
starts to look a little bit like I want
an N type model
where as you add more label noise your
test error is getting harmed but not
infinitely bad
so we'll save the methods on the left
are benign in this case benign fitting
and the methods on the right are
tempered
so I'm going to show a few empirical
results on deep neural networks and then
we're going to look at overfitting in
kernel regression
so I'll extend the earlier example where
we took the binary variant of c410 and
I'm just looking at the full multi-class
classification this is a more
complicated example I'm training the
same wide resonance all of these models
are interpolating the training data even
at 90 label noise I'm fully
interpolating the training data and
something that characterizes being
tempered according to our taxonomy is
this roughly linear shape here that you
get whereas you add more training label
noise you get some harm in your test
error
foreign
other example we have we'll actually
simplify this
just to drive the point home a little
bit we're looking at binary
classification
and we're taking synthetic data sampled
on the 10 sphere
and we're just putting all the labels to
one
and with some probability we flip them
to minus one and we train an MLP so
we're just trying to learn the constant
function
and a consistent method would uh do
pretty well and you can see even as we
increase the amount of training data
from 300 to 360
000 uh simple MLPs this is a three layer
MLP 1024 with a simple MLPs are not
learning the constant function in the
presence of label noise even that
reasonably small label noise
so we look a little bit deeper at early
stopping in deep neural networks so uh
this work that I mentioned before shows
that some shallow and wide rail units
are consistent with early stopping I
think they use the logistic loss we
experimentally look at a problem where
we train resonance on a binary version
of the street view house number problem
the data set so this is uh something a
little bit more difficult than mnist a
little bit easier than cfar
and
we choose the early stopping Epoch for
each of these points here based on Cross
validation on the training subset and we
see on the left when you optimally early
stop you're not interpolating but even
up to 30 label noise you're getting a
very negligible harm on your test error
and yeah
which is noisy yes
so
so you are interpreting or
knowledgeability because on the left
we're not interplay but if you do based
on Cross validation
um
noise on uh one of the faults and
non-vously on the other fold oh I see
yeah right so we we don't look at the
how about tests that in that process
yeah that's that's right yeah
so on the left we've seen an example of
a non-interplane method that really does
clearly Bend towards that benign line
which is very desirable of a method that
is resume
and on the right uh these methods are
all over fit they're perfectly
interpolated in the same data set this
is just a continuation of this
experiment and we see that uh you you
start you start to get this tempered
profile
so to look a little bit more clearly at
that
we look at the time Dynamics in a
regression problem for an MLP so we take
a relu MLP
and we train it with full batch gradient
descent we sample data from a
five-dimensional sphere
and we take the labels to be one with
some gaussian noise
and we plot here the time time and
training so optimization steps and we
plot the MSC for the train and the test
set
and what you see is that
uh in line with naughty slides earlier
up to a point
your training tests are following each
other so you're still under fitting the
noise and they'll reach the space
optimal value at some point
and then once the train MSC
reaches down to zero you see that the
test MSC as you start to overfit the
noise gets worse but then asymptotes
and this is indicative of the type of
tempered overfitting that we're looking
at
and you can see uh we changed the number
of training points to n equals 200 uh it
delays when you fully interpolate but
you still get the same asymptote with
these value MLPs
and we show for n equals 500 the same
thing
uh we we haven't shown a plot here but
one thing that I'll motivate is that if
you change the activation function you
can actually get these harmful
interpolation curves that 90 had shown
where these will just go off
so that concludes the empirical section
on team Journal networks I'm going to
hand it over to
create them to talk about overfitting in
the kernel regression setting
foreign
thanks a lot Neil so I'm gonna be let's
see okay good so I'm going to be
stepping in for uh Jamie Simon who
unfortunately couldn't be here uh due to
a flight mishap but it's too bad but
he'll be here uh the rest of the
workshop I think and so he's really
responsible for the entire affiliate
part of this section uh these are his
slides that I'll just be presenting but
I cut it to him for these results
foreign okay so to recap a bit we've
defined this taxonomy of the three
different types of fitting behaviors
that learning methods can exhibit in the
asset in the asymptotic limit and then
Neil has presented a bunch of empirical
results suggesting that standard types
of deep neural networks when they
interpolate don't actually overfit
benignly
right so benign overfitting means that
even in the asymptotic limit the there's
no asymptotic effect of label noise
right I've been a method that that is
that overfits benignly will be able to
learn the optimal predictor even in the
presence of label noise but that does
not appear to be the case uh in practice
for many standard neural Nets right okay
so this this begs the question that we
have a lot of on the one hand we have a
lot of theoretical results but when
learning methods are uh over fit
benignly on the other hand we have some
practical experiments that suggest uh
actual deep neural networks don't seem
to be benignly overfitting so how do we
resolve this disconnect
um there's two important aspects here
the first aspect is our setting is
slightly different so we're considering
a fixed task and just scaling the number
of samples
uh in particular fixed Dimension and
it's just scaling the number of samples
this is in contrast to many fireworks
where the the problem scales up in
accordance with the number of samples
right here we're not scaling the problem
and the samples we're just considering a
fixed a fixed problem and saying how
does this learning procedure on this
fixed problem behave as you scale
samples
so that's the first uh first potential
Factor explaining the disconnect the
other important factor is going to end
up being the types of assumptions that
you make on the data and particularly
the spectrum of the data and so we can
understand that factor better in the
kernel setting which we're not going to
study
um so so in general the broad question
we want to understand is can we can we
understand when learning methods uh
behave benignly tempered or
catastrophically and this is a very
complex question but we can simplify
this question for kernels and we can
actually get a fairly complete
understanding of this picture under some
heuristic assumptions so that's what I'm
going to talk about now also please feel
free to interrupt me at any time with
any questions I will do my best to
answer them
Okay so
as a as a sort of summary of the results
for kernel aggression we can understand
uh which type of overfitting kernels
exhibit in terms of a in terms of the
spectrum of the kernel on the data okay
so uh essentially any any kernel that
has a ridge is going to be statistically
consistent this is standard the
interesting part is what happens for
religious kernels that interpolate and
by playing with the type of Kernel you
can get either template or catastrophic
Behavior so for example laplacian kernel
so here the x-axis is a number of train
samples the y-axis is the test MSC and
for the LaPlace kernel on the
hypersphere even as you send samples to
Infinity you get some sort of bounded
test risk
on the other hand for the gaussian
kernel in any fixed Dimension without
any ledge parameter that as you send
samples to Infinity at some point the
test energy shoots up and demonstrating
catastrophic overfitting so we can
actually we can prove things about this
under some realistic assumptions but
this is this is what the experimental
results look like yeah
no no yeah so this is not in the plating
this is what I'm saying essentially like
any universal kernel if you set the
ridge parameter appropriately you'll get
consistency that's just that this is
this is a standard result
uh yeah good question this is I think
the setting where we're just learning
the constant function plus gaussian
noise so the constant can be uh yeah
any other questions
I think like she and Sasha's result on
Virtual policy and kernel I feel about
were bound was only either for like even
or odd dimensions
but did this show up at all or does it
just in general that was like a
technical department yeah so so there is
an inconsistency results for the LaPlace
in uh fixed Dimension I think the low
amount itself is fairly weak in terms of
Dimension I believe it was exponential
intervention
um this is like much worse than that
logo and said yes and I don't think
Jamie's techniques depend on the parity
but there's also something new
oh yeah
this taxonomy applies to learning
message genetically whether or not to
get to train set
but what it's been like
so so benign really it means the same
thing as statistically consistent right
we're just using a little bit because
I've been using a literature
so this taxonomy makes sense whether or
not it's been fitting between that it's
particular perhaps particularly
interesting to study preventive learning
methods uh in the context
understanding better how it helps
whether it has been
yeah maybe it's out of the scope of your
your world but
it is a solution
to somehow this will not interpret
anything yeah it's sort of I think there
are many possible fixes like if you
don't even have to go to tablet like you
you do one-pack training then you know
that's seem to be consistent
[Music]
uh
right
yeah
um
so I think we didn't find any closed
form Kyle that that is benign uh so
there's a there's like a spectral
condition if you have I I'll maybe I'll
get to the table there's a particular
spectral condition that it kernel needs
to satisfy in order to be benign and
it's very fragile the very final
Condition it's a similar condition
period like you need a particular kind
of spectral Decay
um you can get it artificially if you
like take the gossip turtle and add a
Delta kernel to it then that's
effectively like the adding an image to
your account so you can cheat and get a
kernel that is that has an effective
image
Without You explicitly putting a list
there but it is kind of cheesy like you
want like a natural
thank you
uh did we look at the APK yeah so we
have some results on that later uh yeah
if you take ntk of standard networks
they behave like template yeah which
sort of what you would expect because if
you do the actual neural network with
experiment you also get a couple days
this
I was wondering like how
do you read for example that the left
part is
should that be an axis which is the
fraction of noisy training oh uh oh yeah
yeah so
so really it's this is benign if this
asymptotes the zero for lit for all sort
of fractions of label noise in this case
because we're in the regression setting
uh it's like if things behave linearly
with respect to the noise because it's
just added ability in the list so you
can just test it for a fixed level of
noise and you should expect things to
scale normally
like yeah there's really in the
regression setting it's really about
variance
um you can you can consider the
experiment where you just try to learn
the constant zero functions plus and
they've got State noise
and this is looking at the
physics
and so now you can just scale the noise
will you cover the intuition for
likewise system
I will cover the results whether I have
good enough information myself is
another question I think Jerry has
something but I was also consistent with
the banana within results okay another
so maybe we can come up with something
okay and there's something they're
actually yeah I should say I think there
is good intuition for this
um Jamie has like a way of thinking
about uh eigen mode learnability that I
can try to discuss a little bit
um
yeah
thank you
any other questions
okay so I'll try to
brief overview of the results and how
the proof works I'm not actually an
expert in this myself so I'll do my best
but we're in this kernel setting where
the the inputs access sampled from some
measure which we will assume to be
uniform over the hypersphere
um the goal
the goal is to is to learn some function
that's the ground tooth plus noise
we're going to learn it with kernel
aggression where we have some PSD kernel
and the the FD is the same the end
samples from the data set
this is the form of the kernel predictor
the regularized kernel predictor for
some for some uh for some legalization
Delta
thing
um some review it's helpful to think of
Kernel learning in terms of the spectrum
of the kernel
so uh just to review the notation that
we'll use uh if you have this kernel
that you can think of as a as an
operator on functions
and
and you once you have this operator you
can decompose the software into its
Spectrum so for example for shift
invariant kernels this is just looking
like it's like a shifting fit for
kernels diagonalized in the in the
Fourier basis right in the the
frequencies are the eigenfunctions
but in general we can look at a kernel
in terms of its eigenfunctions and
eigenvalues and for for natural kernels
we expect the eigenvalues will decay
uh functions index yeah
sorry already said this I just wanted to
clarify some technology that I think the
least other questions suggest I
understand
so consistency means that as n goes to
Infinity you get the test there
yeah
the nine you're defining Defiance and
benign this thing as end goes to
Infinity you recover the optional test
there from a clean distribution uh so so
yeah I'm not I'm not really defining
consistency I want benign to mean
exactly the same thing as statistical
consistency okay so then okay okay so
then consisting means you get foreign
function for the the optimal function
for the clean distribution is the same
as optimal function so that's a
distribution
doesn't necessarily return that
predictor on the noise
[Music]
function for that energy data so the
noise data distribution which I claim is
the same as the output function for the
cleaner distribution right uh and the
limit yeah but there are these like
weird there's these weird situations
okay I guess this really has a point
about the limit of the non-convergence
okay so I guess it's the non-convergence
it's just that I mean all I'm saying is
that I I did the lines necessary to
establish
that to establish that I'm getting to
the nine effect from from from our early
stopped paper and I didn't use the limit
I need to do a couple lines on top of
the finite time guarantee so it wasn't
directed
so just trying to see if I missed
something is it quicker than a few lines
or I'm not sure I understand exactly the
question because the uh
yeah I'm not I we I will only
considering the asymptotic limit though
we're not considering finite science
as an in your paper you also have sort
of finite samples
and there I had to work a little to get
the right thing but okay oh yeah so that
might be possible that if you if you
want to do sort of uh give some kind of
planet sample there might be a
difference yeah I understand what you're
saying that for in the asymptotic limit
once you're on the right side of a half
yeah and it's the right thing so but
yeah okay not interesting I'm sorry it
was my my fault yeah it was just a
question about the planet also
any other questions
um
to decompose everything in the corner
eigen basis including example to the
function that you're trying to learn
so you have some down to function that
you're trying to learn have style
effects and you can decompose this into
the basis of that kernel
so this is just for example doing the
Fourier transform of your downtooth
function in the shift invariant case
okay
um now how do we think about
kernel regression you can equivalently
think about kernel aggression as linear
regression in some lifted feature space
and it's convenient to think of the
lifted speaker lifted feature space in
terms of the eigenfunctions by using the
eigen functions as features
so you can you can write the kernel as
the sum of uh this inner product of the
eigenfunction features
so this is just going to be to give some
flavor of the tools that are used for
the for the analytical results
Okay so
and because equivalently it's a PSD
kernel and so the you can you can use
this feature map uh this eigenfunction
feature map that will induce this kernel
you know you know products according to
K is is exactly the standard in the
product in this lifted space where this
lifted space is evaluations of so if how
do you how do you lift X into into this
lifted space cfx you just evaluate all
of the kernel eigen functions at X
so for example evaluating each frequency
uh each each sinusoid at X
and Things awaited by the eigenvalues
and so you can study and so you know you
can study kernel aggression as linear
regression standard linear regression in
this lifted feature space and that's the
object we want to study we want to study
uh the test and we see of this object
now the analytical tool this is a this
is a heuristic approximation so this is
the one this is a part of a result that
is not vigorously mathematically proven
but this is a analytical heuristic that
has been used in the past in papers in
physics and we've also tested this
heuristic experimentally so this is a
sort of a universality assumption so
what we're saying is we have these
lifted features
State and we want to study linear
regression with the design Matrix as the
lifted features
let's study a an ALT like a proxy for
this design Matrix which is let's let
the listed features instead of the two
features let's let them be
multivariate gaussians with the light
covariance structure
so this is approximating the two design
Matrix as uh with just another Matrix
that matches its second order moments
right and we're now going to study this
gaussian object as if it was a real
object and this will work under the
assumption that the two test errors are
going to be the same
and there's empirical evidence for this
this universality type claim and it also
has some poops in special cases although
not in the case of our work
okay but so there's enough kind of
strategy clear like the this is this is
the main type of assumption yeah
no I think I think everything so just
assume you're you're now studying a
completely different linear regression
setting where you have gaussian design
Matrix but you know like gaussian design
linear regression but with Covance uh
covets by this given by the kernel eigen
Spectrum
uh yes but not but we want to now study
like the not the joint scaling mode we
want to study just the finite like fixed
Dimension into Infinity scaling that's
right
yeah
yeah yeah
so so so like when I overfilling paper
give spectral conditions for benign of a
fitting in this case then I just want to
understand
foreign but also with with uh requiring
like Dimension like scaling both the
covariance structure with the with that
um so okay so then it should like this
should be consistent let me let me see
some of what it is let's see if they're
consistent because I know they're
consistent with your results for the
benign for the benign case
I mean the
Factory
yeah so let me let me like uh we have
some bounds that should pin the predict
sort of the actual exact constant as
well that seem to reduce experience
which is kind of interesting uh so let's
just see if it's consistent with this
um so maybe let me skip this part
because yeah the the many papers that
derive
derive sort of the effective uh what the
tester should be
in discussion or like under discussion
assumption including previous paper and
many others absolutely let me skip this
part uh the point is just if you make
this gaussian assumption you can write
down
fairly simply like what the what the
test MSC should be
okay and so here's the here's the serum
that comes out of it as the assumptions
and let's see how that is consistent
with this so this
okay so the point of the stem is we want
to say uh how does the Spectrum affect
the kind of overfitting
and so this part is the benign of a
fitting condition that's in previous
paper which is if the if the Spectrum
decays just slower than a power law just
barely slower than a power law
um then you'll overfit benignly
on the other hand if you have any kind
of if you have any kind of polynomial
tail then you will exhibit template
overfilling and the limiting test MSE
will be given by the spec exactly by the
exponent
so the the the rate of the of the
spectral Decay is exactly the constant
that determines how far that is exactly
the Gap to benignness
uh I don't think this is is this
uh we didn't have we had bounds up to a
constant so yeah I mean we did a
calculator
in the appendix of that in that case
let's show you
under the secularism
yeah I think it's a sort of an
interesting prediction it's also we have
some experience of sort of aligns up
with with a custom type the gap between
upper a little bit
yeah yeah sounds good all right yeah I
think the sort of God said the case has
been studied in many papers including
this uh yeah
it's nice that you that this Alpha
exactly determined this Gap and as you
as you send this Alpha as you said it's
Alpha plus to one you get the Spinone
kiss and as you increase the outside you
get further and further from benign and
once you're faster than any power law
they can indicator something either to
the minus log log I uh watch it faster
than any power loss
and that's a line to disaster result as
well as you increase the rate of the
spectral Decay Alpha increases and on
Alpha is
all right
so this is just uh like uh like if you
have any videos
yeah
do that yeah uh is this a statements
yeah so the we put this under the for
all eye but I would expect this thing
these things are kind of robust like as
long as it's lovely power like a Decay
oh yeah this is just saying if Lambda is
i to the minus I love I
I to the minus log I
uh yeah
okay and so this is the experiments that
we saw previously
um there's a question about whether we
started ndk
so the the spectral decay of value ntk
is similar to the Decay that you get
from a little plastic kernel in both of
these cases we see the topic that we're
predict
well here's the here's the here's
looking at self-independency
so particularly if you if you're very
respect to the key of the kernel and you
look at the test now let's see
empirically it appears to track with
what this Theory what Jim is still
predicted which is that you get this
exact yeah
what is the this is on the hybrid sphere
oh yeah
yeah it should
definitely uh
something I'm not sure though
does it need to be the same also for all
that
um just uh yeah well does it need to be
the same like the proof we did was just
Google sort of very fragile to that
right but uh I don't think it actually I
don't think it actually results it will
be special
because yeah
like in practice when we did the the DNN
experiments it appeared that almost
anything that is hopefully exist
template and so I think this temperature
feeling is like fairly robust it
shouldn't it shouldn't require any kind
of perspective conditions
thank you
um
yeah to the point of the point of the of
the the sort of analytical results is to
give us insight into what's going on in
deep networks and at least in the kernel
setting
um we can understand it as well as like
many of these papers have understood
exactly how the kind of overfilling
depends on the spectral decay
um we would like to
we would like to extend this
understanding to deep neural networks so
an open question here is
so so one one open question is how how
do we get a more complete understanding
of when deep neural networks overfit uh
benignly or if it a template fashion or
if it overfit catastrophically and
empirically it seemed like all natural
things we tried uh interpolating dnn's
tempered and we don't know how to sort
of make natural design choices that are
both interpolating and benign and I
think this suggests that benign
overfitting might not be the best kind
of conceptual framework to think about
what's happening in interpolating dnms
and maybe temperature fitting is is an
appropriate substitute
but there's many output questions here
we really only have a complete
understanding for this specific kernel
setting
um and even then the police were not
fully legalized so it's open to to see
if we can make them make them completely
like this
they had um the error on a clean
distribution being basically the same as
the level of noise is that right and
with that corresponds like Alpha equals
one in your theory or oh no that that
Alpha is completely different from
detail but yeah that Alpha is changing
the spectral decay of the kernel which
would correspond to something like
changing the architectural the
activation function in the right way the
amount of tempering I guess is it's not
going to affects oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's oh I see I think yes yes yeah
that would definitely correspond to
Alpha equals one here although this is
also classification and that was
regression so
very true
can you go back
oh oh sorry yeah
yeah it is very interesting uh to me
that in the in the classification
setting it seems that the amount of
labor laws you injected the train set is
very close to the amount of noise
if that affected
this is what one is Neighbors will do it
would be produced the noise
oh yeah speaking of which thing the
early on the the preset
yeah so
can you like falsified
if you have examples for it to be if
there's different or is it just the new
one let's be a conflict nurse neighbor
depends on what scale you look at I
guess
the nearest neighborhood
was definitely behave better than this
neighborhood settings right and it's
just that through the the asymptote can
always the the noise I'm not saying that
yeah
but for the the effect of uh
yeah I don't know how to classify that
yet I think you can even you can even do
experiments but you know which we've
done in these past papers take you in
time with the names and only add noise
to some subset like only add noise to
cats or something
uh if you're training on C4 don't I've
noticed all the classes only add nice to
cats now if you were doing one yes
neighborhood then you would expect that
a test time you'll get noisy predictions
for cats but maybe not for other great
protocols and that's that you get that
as well the same look like local noise
affecting things locally
that's sort of suggested evidence that
you should do this yeah
deep networks
uh the ntk converges or like the
effective ntk converted to it
or something
yeah I haven't been able to make the
connection mechanistic like
you you yeah but at some scale they seem
to be absolutely
sorry instead of further questions
thanks for following the questions and
uh and uh yeah
foreign